chinese scientists are close to bringing
out one of those technologies that
stayed way too long in the lab into
reality this is the electric plasma jet
engine now everyone knows how
problematic fossil fuel engines have
been for the environment so several
moves are being made by the world's
brightest and most influential to reduce
carbon emissions and consequently the
effects of global warming some of these
moves include the innovation of new
technologies like carbon capture to
remove the excess carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere another example is the
innovation of technologies that will
make electric vehicles cheaper and
production even cleaner thereby
eliminating the need for fossil fuel
vehicles in this video we'll be looking
at another important move and this one
is the innovation led by a team of
chinese scientists of electric plasma
jet engines that will potentially
replace the current fossil fuel planes
in the aviation industry ready let's get
started the aviation industry's
contribution to co2 emissions the carbon
dioxide emissions from the aviation
industry stand at two percent of all
human human-induced co2 emissions
globally however among transportation
sources the aviation industry is
responsible for 12 percent of carbon
dioxide emissions compared to the 74 of
transportation co2 emissions by road
transport vehicles 12 percent may seem
small however it is significant and with
a projected compound annual growth rate
of seven to fourteen percent it could go
even higher china's electric plasma jet
engine a team of scientists from the
institute of technical science in wuhan
university have announced and
demonstrated that they have created a
potential energy source that could
replace fossil fuels in jet engines this
energy source is air and electricity
zhao tang a professor at wuhan
university and leader of the team says
that the motivation of our work is to
help solve the global warming problems
or into humans use of fossil fuel
combustion engines to power machinery
such as cars and airplanes describing
the design he added that there is no
need for fossil fuel with our design and
therefore there is no carbon emission to
cause greenhouse effects and global
warming the demonstration involved the
use of electricity and microwaves to
induce a pressurized airstream into
producing an impressive amount of thrust
the prototype thruster was able to lift
a steel ball weighing one kilogram over
a quartz tube with a diameter of 24
millimeters when scaled up to the size
of a working jet engine this plasma
engine prototype is able to provide the
same thrust needed to propel a jet or
plane according to tang our results
demonstrated that such a jet engine
based on microwave air plasma can be a
potentially viable alternative to the
conventional fossil fuel jet engine
therefore in theory constructing a jet
engine with an array of plasma prototype
thrusters while providing it with a
constant stream of air and high power
microwave sources would be able to
replace conventional fossil fuel engines
and subsequently eliminate two percent
of global co2 emissions this ability to
scale the prototype thruster to an
actual plane size engine is what the
team of scientists are currently working
on nasa dawn space probe's ion thruster
now some of you might feel the need to
mouth off in the comments section about
how plasma engines kinda already exist
the other kind of engine that's similar
to the plasma is the ion thruster the
nasa dawn space probe moves in space by
making use of a gas like xenon gas the
ion thruster shoots out positive ions of
the gas to propel the probe an ion is
either positively or negatively charged
depending on if the atom has lost or
gained an electron respectively the ion
thruster has an ionization chamber where
the ionization of the xenon gas occurs
it does this by bombarding the gas with
electrons inside the electron chamber
the resulting positive ions or kessians
are attracted to negatively charged ions
therefore in order to prevent the
cations from reacting with the electrons
that are inside the ionization chamber a
stream of electrons are being emitted on
the outside of the thruster this way
when the positive xenon ions are shot
out of the ion thruster they react with
the electrons and get neutralized
instead of getting reintroduced into the
ionization chamber limitations to the
ion thruster however the ion thruster
faces one major setback in terms of
transportation and that setback is the
existence of forces in earth's
atmosphere in space the nasa dawn space
probe is effective for space travel
because there are zero forces opposing
the motion of objects in fact in space
you could propel yourself by bouncing
off a surface with something as tiny as
a strand of hair however the plasma
thruster proves to have the potential to
surmount these atmospheric forces to
enable the plane to fly vertically in
earth's atmosphere and one thing that
differentiates the plasma thruster from
the nasa dawn space probe ion thruster
is the fact that it makes use of plasma
rather than a special gas like xenon gas
what is plasma
so what is plasma well plasma is the
fourth state of matter that's right
alongside liquid solid and gaseous
states if you're just learning this
you'll be even more surprised to learn
that plasma is also the most abundant
state of matter in the observable
universe and it has special
characteristics like being able to
conduct electricity and glowing up as
well one important feature of matter is
the ability to move from one state to
another this is called phase change with
this we have been able to create plasma
by providing gases with enough energy so
that it gets ionized in nature this
energy can be provided via high
temperatures like the sun or through
electrical fields like lightning in
essence lightning ionizes the air around
it turning it into plasma then the
plasma in turn allows the smooth flow of
the electrical current through it plasma
in the prototype engine however the
plasma prototype developed by the team
does not use a large amount of heat or a
powerful electrical field to convert the
stream of air to plasma instead it makes
use of high concentrations of microwaves
from the microwave generator to convert
the air to plasma there is an electrical
spark in the inlet of the tube that
heats the plasma in the quartz tube
creating concentration of hot plasma and
consequently high pressure that will
generate the much needed propulsion in
future planes this propulsion has an
amount of thrust that is comparable to a
combustion jet engine per square meter
can the plasma engine scale to larger
jets they were recorded to have produced
11 newtons of thrust in a 400 watt
microwave jet prototype engine while
about 4 newtons of that was from the
pressure of the compressed air alone
this means that the prototype generates
around 28 newtons per kilowatt however
the figure can easily be higher or lower
based on the flow rate of the compressed
air as well as the amount of microwave
energy being used this is the current
challenge with scaling the prototype
onto jet engines of a conventional plane
for example civilization changing
technology so there you have it the
aviation industry is one of the most
important means of transportation today
and it'll definitely become even more
important as we move into the future if
zhao tang and his extraordinary team of
scientists are successful or to be
honest if anyone is successful in
perfecting the plasma jet engine to
scale to large jet engines then we could
be looking at a cleaner and safer future
for the rest of humanity scratch that
the future would be safer for all life
on the planet and maybe even in the
universe thankfully the fuel needed for
this new engine is the most abundant
fuel that we could ever dream of and
most importantly to the best of our
understanding it leaves no harmful
residue or byproduct as well this is a
technology that's been waiting in the
wings however it's looking very likely
to fly and maybe it'll take us into the
future with it but what do you think is
the plasma jet engine a waste of time
what other technology do you think can
replace fossil fuel engines let us know
in the comments below and if you enjoyed
this video make sure to give it a like
and check out more awesome ones on the
simply tech channel thanks for watching
and we'll see you next time